taking your calls with chris hogan
america's voice on retirements this
half-hour the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five you can
follow chris on facebook twitter on his
website at chris hogan 360 chris hogan
360 dot-com and if you go there there's
a tool on his website i highly recommend
is completely free it's fairly easy to
use it takes about ten minutes to use
the thing called your our IQ you need to
know what your number is you know what
your retirement number is and your
retirement IQ your our IQ your retire
inspired quotient so chris talked about
that for just a second how long does it
take to do it and and and what are you
going to come up with when you get your
are IQ yeah david to only takes a matter
of minutes and by plugging that in
you're going to tap into your dream and
talk about that with your spouse
accountability partner you're going to
plug in some basic information how much
money you currently have invested how
much money you want to live on in
retirement plugging that stuff in and
then how many years you want to retire
it's going to tell you the dollar amount
you need to live your dream it's also if
you're a little bit behind it's going to
tell you exactly how much you need to
start to invest right now to catch up
and live your dream so I love the tool
it's an opportunity to shine the light
on this topic because I don't want
people fearful anymore I want them to
understand what's at stake and then I
need them to follow the process you plug
it in you could have an oh crap moment
but at least you know what you got deal
with and now you can start to make some
changes now yes
alright now we talked about the 30s and
for 20s and 30s the 40s and 50s so
someone's listening right now that's
over 60 mm-hmm they have that running
through their mind it's too late for me
for retirement talk to them I'm going to
tell you right now that it is not too
late what you're going to have to do is
get serious though we're going to have
to make some sacrifices no more just
going with the flow and we're going to
act like everything's fine we got you
have to get serious and we have to start
making sacrifices look to sell some
stuff figure out ways to earn some extra
income be smart about when you take
retirement in Social Security
excuse me so you don't want to take that
prior to 70 you can make 125 percent
more in your benefits if you wait till
age 70
you want to gather some information live
within your means and I want you to be
clear on this whatever you do have
tucked aside
don't touch that money that is
retirement but we've got to get focused
and we've got to sacrifice some stuff
you may sacrifice a little bit of sleep
but you can do this and your dream may
not look like how you dreamed it would
be when you're in your 30s but I promise
you this if you wake up and get serious
your dream doesn't have to turn into a
nightmare but you have to you have to
start working and being very intentional
you know if you invest aggressively for
most households by getting out of debt
at that age even is starting at 60 years
old you could end up with several
hundred thousand dollars I mean it might
be 100 or 200 but listen that's a whole
lot different than trying to live on
Social Security that's right you might
not have two million that but but it's a
whole lot different and they've let me
just let everyone know out there the
average Social Security payout is
thirteen thousand a year so if you're
out there and you have this fictitious
dream that Social Security Social
Security is going to save the day what
kind of dream can you live off thirteen
grand
eleven hundred bucks a month it what
kind of dream and so with that let's
look at this and let's acknowledge okay
something's got to change
so if you have a car payment let's get
that card sold or attack it and pay it
off you've got to start to look around
and look at things identify what you can
do don't focus on what you didn't do and
that'll help you stay proactive there
you go all right phone number here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ben is in Canada Ben your
retirement question for Chris Hogan a
huge element for taking my call okay I
just started to do the debt snowball
thing about two months ago now I'm 50 if
I listen to Dave you kill all retirement
investments no 401 K s yeah for one case
and you attack it with a vengeance which
I'm ready to do but I'm so scared I died
fifty years old I don't want to let go
of my 15% for one case per month I want
to keep on keeping the 50% per month as
401 K and then with the rest attack the
snowball is that good or should I just
kill the 401 case for like two or three
years and go back on it after how much
debt do you have my cell TVs in my
salary's 80,000 a year I have 80,000 and
debt on
what is well it's credit cards and nasty
divorce and things like that you know so
much of its car I just have the little
Honda it's like three hundred dollars a
month how much is out on the car
about eight thousand okay so eight of
the eighty thousand his car that's all
the rest of its credit cards and what um
well I went to a divorce at to sell the
house the house gave me a capital gain
to pain everything so okay okay I melt
eighty thousand got you okay okay now
bin I tell you you know number one I can
graduate you because you're focused on
this issue at age fifty you're seeing it
you know where you are and I'm going to
tell you if I'm intense if I'm staying
focused then I would definitely pause
the 401k contribution pause that so you
can take that extra income and redirect
it toward this debt now I hear the
passion in your voice and you don't like
that idea but that's the very reason why
you should do it because it's going to
get you motivated I promise you you
won't take two or three years you'll do
extra stuff and take on an extra job to
get this debt out of your life so you
can get back to investing now listen I
want you to think of this debt payment
that you're making right now
how much argue building their legacy
you're not building yours let's get your
income back let's give you a raise by
getting out of debt then you can focus
on retirement now the at $80,000 income
with $80,000 worth of debt if you roll
up your sleeves and live on absolutely
nothing which the bad news is you've
been through a divorce the good news is
you don't have to talk to anybody into
this but you and you know you can live
on nothing and so this should be done in
two years but that's literally beans and
rice rice and beans and that's not going
to set you back so far that you can't
catch up that's right and Dave he said
he sold the house or went through that
with the divorce right now he should not
be focused on buying a home now that
that he's going to rent there is no sin
against renting rent right where you are
keep your expenses low and let's get
this debt out of your life there you go
that's exactly how it's done
all right open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five so
Chris we're going to be in Baton Rouge
doing smart money on September the 17th
two weeks away
then you and I will be in Atlanta doing
the smart money event the smart money
event is walking right up the baby steps
folks and so regardless of where you are
in the wealth building process whether
you're just getting started you're brand
new or whether you're deep into this and
you're wanting to know some investment
advice we're going to cover all of it
that night and it walks you from zero
all the way up into wealth and baby step
seven which is wealth and outrageous
generosity and so on yeah we want you to
come through that and Chris and I've had
so much fun doing these they've been
very very popular let me tell you about
Andrews you have like 300 tickets left
and so you need to get on my look to the
report this morning there's less than
500 tickets available in Atlanta for
September the 24th Baton Rouge is
September 17th Nashville October the 8th
I think there's about a thousand left
there at the Grand Ole Opry and that's
going to be that's a huge venue it's
almost 5,000 people and it's it's
rocking already and Oklahoma City and
Louisville exactly the same situation
November 5th and November 17th and Chris
is going to be doing retire inspired his
event in Kansas City November the 2nd
Denver November the 12th and Oklahoma
City December the 5th now tickets for
all of these things anything you hear us
talk about you can always get them at
Dave Ramsey comm or any of these events
you can get at chris hogan 360 calm as
well while you're looking at your riq
and getting that done and and you can
call customer care at triple-eight
22-piece chris quickly before we run out
of time what are you going to be
covering at these particular retire
inspired events where you have an event
just about retirement
yes sir sounds like an old people it is
not an old people thing it's so smart
people think Dave just like retirement
I'm going to be walking people through
the process of how do you do this
retirement thing and how do you do it
with dignity I want people to understand
it I'm going to unpack it in the
two-hour event and walk people through
just like I sit and used to coach people
kneecap to kneecap years ago and so I
want people to come out I don't care if
you're 14 or 84 come out and join me
understand the importance of what's at
stake right here with your retirement
dream I want people Dave I get so
excited about this the opportunity to
travel across the country and help
people kind of plug into this
information
here's some hard truth but leave out
with wisdom and knowledge that they can
immediately start to apply and that's
why I want people retiring inspired I
want them excited and I look forward to
going to Kansas City Denver and Oklahoma
City there you go it's going to be a
blast
so check it all out at Chris Hogan 360
calm or Dave Ramsey calm and we'd love
to have you visit us on any one of those
events it's going to be a lot of fun
we're going to be traveling all over the
place and it has started officially
right now there you go hey Chris thanks
for being with me thank you for having
me dude alright that puts us our the
Dave Ramsey show in the books our thanks
to James childs our producer Blake
Thompson our executive producer and
Kelly Daniel our associate producer I am
Dave Ramsey Yost and we will be back